hi guys it's silver at again and since
the last couple of episodes were mostly
time lapse saying and that didn't quite
work out because my for some reason my
computer still can't take this park and
I've done many things like you can see
my theming father is absolutely messed
up I've only got three themes that's
because I removed all of the custom
scenery and or everything basically that
I had installed that I didn't need for
this park I just got rid of it so not
that resulted in some weird scenery
things because I did also remove the
in-game senior even so that was weird
also got more RAM and allowed Rocco
second 32 even use it my hard drive
space that's left to for the RAM and of
court 150 gigs left so that should be
good and I even got so far as to use the
vacuum cleaner on my laptop even though
that's a really bad idea just to make
sure that there's no dust in it so it
would overheat and still roller coaster
tycoon 3 crushed oh I have no clue at
this point but just [ __ ] saving and
opening the game and then crushing the
game opening it again it's really
annoying so i hope this this probably
won't get settled so that's a really big
problem actually for me but i did decide
to just do a quick episode right here
and just do some talking and some
[ __ ] saving because basically i've
got i still got two camps of that people
watch my let's play we've gotten the
people who watch it for the commentary
we're going to get mad if I don't do it
in if I keep doing time lapses and
people kind of watch for the time lapses
and yeah of course it's pretty much
impossible to make them both happy so
yeah I guess I got to find a balance so
today is more of a talking day and more
of a commentary day also and like I said
because of technical issues because it's
really hard to keep a time-lapse going
because I I need it to close I needed to
open the game do a quick time lapse tank
would crash like after 30 minutes and if
I then try to open it again it just
doesn't work anymore land just need to
wait a day or something like that it's
really really annoying and I mean I
don't really care as long as I like if I
have leg
or other technical issues I don't really
mind as long as I can just keep building
and keep making stuff and keep making
episodes but this is just a major
problem nuts yeah basically disabling me
from playing this game and as a really
really big problem to me because you
know I'm addicted to this and I just
want to keep making videos and I just
want I just want to keep making this
let's play but that's really hard when
this game doesn't work so yeah that's
not really great so now I'm saving up my
money which is going to take thousands
of years in order to buy a pc but i am
pretty much broke now i'm not broke boy
yeah i don't have too much money on my
hands alright though let's talk about
this building because i i'm not sure
what to do with this let's just see i
can use some walls from station gym set
yeah it should though yeah i don't know
let's just see you then let's take a
diagonal here let's just get as many
towers as I can that's generally a good
approach when it comes to medieval
buildings just towers everywhere I mean
it's a theme park it doesn't have to be
realistic some people are like realism
is everything but yeah it is a theme
park and if you don't if you didn't know
that architecture in a theme park is
completely different from architecture
in real life so you don't really have to
pay attention to it being realistic you
just have to pay attention to if I if I
were any theme park and I'd see
buildings like this could I understand
the theme could I understand what's
going on could I think that this would
be a logical thing and that's pretty
much with this seems to be to me though
I must admit the theming for this park
is ridiculous it's but because there's
so much steaming going on in this park
already and I'm not even done with it
yeah I mean it's just this is a hill of
them this is a hill with the roller
coaster on him these buildings don't
even have a function they're just here
to make everything
even crazy and even yeah how do I put it
even crazier basically that was a good
way to put it and yeah I'm first I first
I was like yeah that's impossible but
then I was like let's take a look at
Fantasy Island and they've got like
crazy buildings all over the place
especially with that invert witted
calling and the black mama and also with
their weird the log flume with an
airtime Hill and all that cool stuff so
yeah that's actually a really cool park
that's the kind of bike that I would
visit to look at the [ __ ] buildings
because I that's who I am I look at
buildings oh well battlements
battlements always when you're building
castles one good way to make a building
look like a castle is bad battlements
that's all one of the things that makes
a difference the other thing of course
is like I said towers towers everywhere
makes everything look like a castle even
with medieval buildings as you can see
so kinda looks like a castle I mean
alpine buildings sorry now for the
windows I'm probably going to zero
cheese set again I might actually turn
this into a bit of the tutorial Connor
yeah so I usually take these windows
because they look steampunky that's all
and because they are made of glass that
actually makes the difference because
these look pretty modern so using this
on old walls and stuff makes it look
even more steampunky a medieval Alpine
ish which is our non-existent theme but
I'm using it anyway now this is the
harder part I don't exactly know what to
do with that I know though that was it
in this set yes it was why you had the
bay thingies I could potentially use one
of these bay things but
that doesn't look too awesome actually
though doesn't look too bad either could
I do that mmm no that's weird and I'd
have to add a floor and everything and I
still I can still see the rocks plus it
comes pretty close to the roller coaster
so that's generally not a very good idea
now I do feel like this corner of this
wall is a very good place to either
built one of these things or a nicer
looking tower yeah let's go for the
nicer looking tower the hexagon thing
that's in this part of the set that's
always one of the best things you can do
I mean if you want to alpine buildings
are basically squares with loads of
details and weird things attached to it
and these things are one of their one of
the building elements that you can use
to make an Alpine building look less
boring without too much effort now you
do want to get this one on the middle
not slightly on the side you want to get
it exactly on the middle of that thing
and then of course you want to get the
corresponding roof part okay now I try
to make roofs with different kinds of
colors so this roof is going to be it
does need to be a slightly one of these
grayish colors and this looks like pew
Anna looks good enough never mind oh
wait [ __ ] I totally messed up on it
sorry Wow no that's the wrong side you
need to get this side holy [ __ ] major
feel that is a major feel okay now then
that looks a lot better then roof the
same greenish koukash colo
Oh does some weird [ __ ] the battlements
whatever
I don't want to make it any higher so
let's just keep it like that so I don't
think I don't think it's too terrible
now on the other side here though I'd
probably want to add a different kind of
tower the question is what kind of tower
so I've already used a couple of those
square towers with with the bell tower
vinny's so that'd be boring though now I
could give it a shot let's just when it
comes to towers it's not the shape that
makes the difference it's what you add
to the tower and the roof so don't worry
about having the same square tower
everywhere as long as you still got
different roofs to work with and
different windows and stuff like that
you can still make it look like pretty
much different tower I mean seriously
that makes a huge difference like you
know I mean this tower looks a lot
different from like a tower like this
one even though they're practically the
same I just use different balls and a
different roof on it on that one but
when it comes to size and they're the
same I mean size and shape yeah okay
that could look good but right now it's
not quite doing it for me um it's
possibly sat time for the efteling set
oh god I have a love-hate relationship
with this set because it's it looks
great and you can this is a great set
for alpine buildings actually but the
only problem is user friendliness is not
something it's not a word that this set
appears to know because it's absolutely
terrible to work with no thumbnails and
I mean I can still kind of understand
what about because on Dutch but if you
don't speak the Dutch language you up
you're going to get lost in this and
it's terrible but when it comes to looks
this is this is one of my favorite sets
actually and yeah to be honest even I
have a hard time sometimes finding the
right pieces
let's see okay now this is a piece I
need and I'm going to use another piece
combined with this one which makes it
look like a like a cornice which it kind
of isn't but it makes it look like it so
good enough for me I asked yes this site
is magnificent where was it yeah this
one these two pieces when you when you
mix them I don't know it kind of makes
it look like a very cool corners to me
not sure if they're if you're supposed
to use them like this but you know I
like it okay corners are always a bit
annoying okay time to time for [ __ ]
saving because I don't want to lose
anything
you